.
>>> TOPPING OUR POLITICS LEAD, A
REPUBLICAN FACE-OFF IN ARIZONA
COULD FORESHADOW THE 24
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY RACE.
THE STATE'S UPCOMING REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY FOR GOVERNOR HAS QUICKLY
MORPHED INTO SOMETHING OF A
BITTER PROXY WAR BETWEEN FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AND VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
AS CNN'S KYUNG LAH REPORTS.
>> A SHOWDOWN IN THE DESERT OVER
THE FUTURE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
MIKE PENCE AND DONALD TRUMP AT
ODDS YET AGAIN.
THIS TIME IN THE HOTLY CONTESTED
GOP PRIMARY FOR ARIZONA
GOVERNOR.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS
ENDORSED REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
KERRY LAKE.
>> SHE'S MY COMPLETE AND TOTAL
ENDORSEMENT.
>> A FORMER REPUBLICAN.
>> I REGISTERED AS A REPUBLICAN.
>> TURNED INDEPENDENT.
>> REALLY FED UP.
>> TURNED DEMOCRAT.
>> I REGISTERED AS A DEMOCRAT.
>> TURNED REPUBLICAN AGAIN.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, PARTY
OF SOLUTIONS.
>> HER CAMPAIGN IS CENTERED ON
THE LIE THAT DONALD TRUMP BEAT
JOE BIDEN.
>> THE WHOLE U.S., AS LONG AS AN
ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT IS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> SHE SPOUTS FAR RIGHT
CONSPIRACIES.
>> WE HAD MAJOR ELECTION FRAUD.
200,000 MINIMUM BALLOTS WERE
TRAFFICKED BY MULES.
>> I'M KERRY LAKE.
>> LIKE TRUMP, LAKE MADE HER
NAME ON TELEVISION.
THE FORMER ARIZONA LOCAL NEWS
ANCHOR HAS ALSO BORROWED FROM
HIS PLAYBOOK, FREQUENTLY
ATTACKING THOSE IN HER OLD
PROFESSION.
>> FAKE NEWS.
I GOT AMBUSHED BY CNN OUTSIDE.
>> I THINK KERRY LAKE HAS WHAT
IT TAKES TO GET US TO WHERE WE
NEED TO GET BACK ON TRACK FOR
OUR FAMILIES AND GIVES US HOPE.
>> LAKE HAS A MESSAGE FOR A
BASE, AND ONLY THAT GROUP.
THE QUESTION IS, IS THAT GROUP
LARGE ENOUGH TO WIN THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION?
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> REPUBLICAN GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE KAREN TAYLOR ROBISON
ANOTHER LEADING CONTENDER FOR
THE GOP NOMINATION, SAYS IT'S
NOT.
>> HOW DO YOU RUN AGAINST AN
OPPONENT WHO IS BACKED BY A
POPULAR FORMER PRESIDENT?
>> IF YOU LIKE DONALD TRUMP'S
POLICIES AND RECORD OF LIMITED
GOVERNMENT, LOW TAX,
PRO-BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT, AND
SOMEBODY WITH A TRACK RECORD OF
SUCCESS, I'M YOUR CANDIDATE.
IF YOU WAND SOMEBODY WHO IS A
BIG PERSONALITY, I THINK KERRY
LAKE IS YOUR CANDIDATE.
>> ROBISON'S STRATEGY TO WIN THE
NOMINATION IS TO CONSOLIDATE
SUPPORT OF TRADITIONAL
CONSERVATIVES HELPED BY PENCE'S
RALLY.
>>.
>> SHE ALSO HAS THE SUPPORT OF
ARIZONA'S OUTGOING REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR, DOUG DUCEY, WHO
ATTACKED LAKE'S SUPPORT FOR
TRUMP AS A MATTER OF POLITICAL
CONVENIENCE.
>> LAKE'S MISLEADING VOTERS WITH
NO EVIDENCE.
SHE'S BEEN TAGGED BY HER
OPPONENTS WITH A NICKNAME, FAKE
LAKE.
WHICH SEEMS TO BE STICKING.
>> A DELICATE DANCE FOR ROBISON,
COURTING THE RIGHT WING MEANS
SOWING DOUBTS ABOUT THE 2020
ELECTION.
>> WHERE ARE YOU ON THE 2020
ELECTION?
>> AT A MINIMUM, THE ELECTION
WAS NOT FAIR.
I KNOW PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR A
DIFFERENT ANSWER FROM ME, BUT
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT, YOU
KNOW, THERE WAS CONCERN FROM A
LOT OF VOTERS.
>> YOU LOOK AT THE PRIMARIES WE
JUST WENT THROUGH IN SOME OF
THESE OTHER STATES, MESSAGES TO
TAKE AWAY ARE CERTAINLY THE
DONALD TRUMP ENDORSEMENT IS A
POWERFUL ASSET BUT NOT THE
SILVER BULLET.
>> ARIZONA'S PRIMARY WILL BE
ANOTHER SIGNAL FOR NATIONAL
REPUBLICANS.
KYUNG LAH, CNN, PHOENIX.
>> OUR THANKS TO KYUNG LAH FOR
THAT REPORT.
SCOTT JENNINGS LET'S START WITH
YOU, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
PROXY WAR IN ARIZONA?
WE'RE SEEING IT THERE.
WE SAW IT EARLIER IN GEORGIA
WITH, AGAIN, TRUMP BACKING THE
PERSON THAT WAS ALL IN ON FULL
ELECTION LIES VERSUS THE
INCUMBENT GOVERNOR WHO PENCE
SUPPORTED.
>> DYNAMICS HERE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT IN GEORGIA.
PENCE HAD THE UPPER HAND
SUPPORTING BRIAN KEMP WHO WAS
FAR AHEAD.
IN THIS CASE, TRUMP'S ENDORSED
CANDIDATE LAKE IS SLIGHTLY
AHEAD, ALTHOUGH I THINK IT'S AN
EXTREMELY CLOSE RACE.
PENCE IS ALIGNED WITH THE
OUTGOING GOVERNOR DOUG DUCEY WHO
IS EXTREMELY CONSERVATIVE, BUT
HE CAME UNDER TRUMP'S NEGATIVE
GAZE FOR NOT DOING WHAT HE
WANTED HIM TO DO ON ELECTION
STUFF.
AS MUCH AS THIS IS A RACE IN THE
MOMENT, IT IS A LITTLE BIT OF
PROXY FOR THE ARGUMENT TO COME
FOR MIKE PENCE, WHICH IS, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GET
BACK TO A REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT
IS FOCUSED ON THE FUTURE AND NOT
RELITIGATED THE 2020 ELECTION.
IF YOU LISTEN TO HIS SPEECH
TODAY, HE WAS NOT FOCUSED ON
DONALD TRUMP AT ALL BUT REALLY
FOCUSED ON CONSERVATIVE ISSUES
AND TAKING TRADITIONAL
CONSERVATIVE SHOTS AT ROBISON'S
OPPONENT, LAKE.
THIS IS A BIT OF A SETUP FOR HIS
ARGUMENT TO COME IN HIS RACE FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2024.
>> KASIE, TAKE A LISTEN TO KATIE
HOBBS THIS MORNING ON CNN.
SHE'S THE ARIZONA SECRETARY OF
STATE.
SHE'S THE DEMOCRAT RUNNING FOR,
SHE HASN'T WON THE NOMINATION
YET, BUT LIKELY WILL BE THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE FOR GOVERNOR.
SHE SAYS THAT THERE REALLY
ACTUALLY ISN'T THAT MUCH OF A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES, EVEN
THOUGH ONE IS DEEPLY ALL IN ON
THE LIES AND THE OTHER ONE IS
PLAYING FTSE WITH THEM.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THERE'S VERY LITTLE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN EITHER OF
THESE CANDIDATES ON THEIR POLICY
POSITIONS.
EVEN KAREN TAYLOR ROBISON SAID
IN AN INTERVIEW LAST WEEK THAT
SHE COULDN'T NAME A SINGLE
POLICY DIFFERENCE.
SHE, TOO, HAS CALLED INTO
QUESTION THE 2020 ELECTION.
AND HAS REFUSED TO SAY IF SHE
WOULD ACCEPT BOTH THE RESULTS OF
THE 2022 ELECTION OR CERTIFY THE
2024 ELECTION IF SHE IS
GOVERNOR.
>> IS SHE RIGHT?
>> LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT WHY
SHE'S SAYING THAT.
IT'S BECAUSE SHE KNOWS SHE'LL
PROBABLY HAVE TO RUN AGAINST
EITHER ONE OF THEM, SDPITS RR
GOING TO BE HARDER FOR HER TO
RUN AGAINST ROBISON IF SHE WINS
THE NOMINATION SO SHE'S TRYING
TO MAKE THEM LOOK EQUALLY
EXTREME.
I DO THINK THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIVE DIFFERENCE, EVEN
THOUGH YES, PLAYING FOOTSY WITH
THE ELECTION LIES IS
PROBLEMATIC.
THERE ARE CLEARLY REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES WHO ARE TRYING TO PUT
TRUMP IN THE PAST.
TRYING TO SAY OKAY, VOTERS, WE
GET YOUR CONCERNS BUT WE HAVE TO
MOVE FORWARD.
THAT'S MIKE PENCE'S ENTIRE
ARGUMENT.
AS OPPOSED TO CANDIDATES LIKE
CARRY LAKE WHO ARE HUNG UP ON
WHAT TRUMP IS HUNG UP ON, THE
2020 ELECTION.
I THINK THERE'S A MATERIAL
DIFFERENCE AND MS. HOBBS KNOWS
IT WILL BE EASIER TO RUN AGAINST
LAKE THAN ROBISON.
>> I THINK HOBBS SHOULD BE
FORCED TO ANSWER THE QUESTION
WHY THE DEMOCRAT, SHE'S SO UPSET
ABOUT ELECTION DENIALISM AND THE
FATE OF OUR DEMOCRACY, WHY THE
DEMOCRAT COMMITTEE IS SPENDING
MONEY TO GET LAKE THE
NOMINATION.
THEY'RE FOR LAKE, TRUMP IS FOR
LAKE.
TO ME, THIS IS MASS HYPOCRISY.
>> THEY THINK SHE'S EASIER TO
BEAT.
>> IS THAT OKAY?
>> PLAYING WITH FIRE.
>> THE DOG IS GOING TO CATCH THE
CAR ONE OF THESE DAYS.
>> IT'S NOT IMMORAL.
IT MIGHT BE A BAD STRATEGY, BUT
THERE'S NOTHING IMMORAL ABOUT
IT.
>> THAT'S WHAT CLAIRE McCASKILL
DID WITH TODD AKIN.
BUT YES, IT IS PLAYING WITH
FIRE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT YOU?
TO YOU THINK THERE'S A
SUBSTANTIVE DIFFERENCE ON THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORY ELECTION LIE
STUFF?
>> I THINK THERE'S A SUBSTANTIVE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BEING ALL IN
ON THE IDEA THAT THE ELECTION
WAS STOLEN AND BASICALLY BEING
ALL IN ON MAGA, WHICH IS WHAT WE
HAVE WITH LAKE.
IT'S NOT JUST THIS.
SHE'S JUST ALL IN ON WHATEVER
TRUMP IS DOING AND HOWEVER TRUMP
APPROACHES THINGS.
SO I THINK THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE.
I STILL THINK IT'S HIGHLY
PROBLEMATIC THAT EVEN THE
CANDIDATES THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE THE SANE ONES FEEL COMPELLED
TO PRETEND THAT THE ELECTION
MIGHT HAVE BEEN -- LIKE
SOMETHING MIGHT HAVE GONE WRONG.
THIS IS INSANE.
>> YOU SAW THIS IN GEORGIA WHERE
EVEN PEOPLE LIKE BRIAN KEMP AND
BRAD RAFFENSPERGER, WHO HELD THE
LINE AND WERE STALWART ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF THE ELECTION, THEN
CAME FORWARD AND SUPPORTED ALL
THESE CHANGES TO ELECTION LAW
THAT WERE REALLY NOT NECESSARY
TO MAKE GIVEN THE FACT THAT THEY
ENDORSED HOW SUBSTANTIVE AND
CLEAR AND FAIR AND FORTHRIGHT
THEIR ELECTION WAS.
>> RIGHT, THERE WAS REALLY NO
JUSTIFICATION FOR ALL THE
CHANGES IN ELECTION LAWS THAT
REPUBLICANS PUSHED THROUGH IN
GEORGIA, OTHER THAN TO TRY TO
APPEASE THAT BASE WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
AND SO EVEN WITH KEMP AND
RAFFENSPERGER, THEY STOOD UP TO
TRUMP, THEY SAID THE ELECTION
WAS NOT STOLEN.
JOE BIDEN WON.
BUT THEN IN SOME WAYS THEY STILL
CAVED TO THE BASE AND SOME WAYS
THEY STILL ADHERED TO THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE ELECTION LIES
EVEN IF THEY HAD -- EVEN IF THEY
SAID THE ELECTION LIES WEREN'T
TRUE, THEY STILL ADHERED TO
THOSE PRINCIPLES.
THESE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
DON'T THINK THEY CAN WIN THE
PRIMARY WITHOUT DOING THAT.
>> THEY CAN'T.
THAT'S THE REALITY.
THIS IS WHAT DONALD TRUMP HAS
UNLEASHED.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HIM AND
ALL OF THE REPUBLICAN NOMINEES
OF THE PAST WAS THAT INSTEAD OF
ACKNOWLEDGING THERE WAS AN
ELEMENT TO THE PARTY THAT WANTED
THIS KIND OF THING, LOOK AT JOHN
McCAIN AND SARAH PALIN.
I THINK THEY WOULD LOOK BACK AND
SAY THAT WAS A MISTAKE, BUT HE
WOULD AT LEAST STAND UP AND PUSH
BACK AGAINST THE ELEMENT OF THE
PARTY.
TRUMP ENABLED IT, TALKED TO THE
WHITE SUPREMACISTS, THE OAT
KEEPERS, THE PROUD BOYS, STAND
BACK AND STAND BY.
NOW THAT'S GIVEN ALL OF THEM
PERMISSION AND PUT REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES, I MEAN, THIS IS A
CHALLENGE FOR EVERYONE WHO
CLAIMS THEY WANT TO RESTORE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AFTER TRUMP.
IT IS VERY HARD WHEN 30% OF THE
PARTY IS THIS WAY, TO ACTUALLY
WIN A PRIMARY IN A DIFFERENT
KIND OF WAY.
>> THE ONLY THING I WOULD SAY IS
DONALD TRUMP HAD A TURNKEY
OPERATION.
BASICALLY, THIS WAS SET UP BY
REPUBLICANS, BY ALL OF THESE
GOOD REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ELECTION FRAUD FOR
AS LONG AS I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN POLITICS, WHO HAVE BEEN
CLAIMING DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
STEALING ELECTIONS FOR AS LONG
AS I HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING
POLITICS.
SO DONALD TRUMP WALKED INTO A
SLIP STREAM WHERE IT WAS ALL SET
UP AND EVERYBODY WAS ALREADY
PRIMED TO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
WHAT DEMOCRATS DO.
I MEAN, WE COULD GO THROUGH ALL
THE DIFFERENT PHONY
CONTROVERSIES THAT HAPPENED.
>> IT GOES BACK TO THE SOUTH AND
JIM CROW.
>> I'M NOT EVEN TALKING IN MORE
RECENT TIMES.
A.C.O.R.N., THE OBSESSION OVER
THAT.
THERE'S ALSO THIS IDEA THAT
DEMOCRATS STEA